you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman chess calms
tactics trainer I'm going to do a group
of three puzzles and simply share my
thoughts along the way so in this first
one we're playing as black and my first
impression is that we can give checkmate
this king is really short on squares
we're down a queen we need to make
something happen really soon like really
soon actually because Queen to g8 is
going to be made so this one shouldn't
be too bad this is a really clever one
okay I see the solution now huh yeah
this bishop arriving on f2 or e 7 with
check will be deadly this is the only
safe that King can't move to a safe
Square so check here's just to give
check I think there might even be more
than one solution here yeah I'm pretty
sure there's more than one solution with
this one I believe rook f4 or even rook
to e4 wins no I'm mistaken on rookie
four if the bishop blocks then we play
Bishop e7 me however on rookie four
there's g4 and we are not so quick to
land a check next with our bishop the
trick here is to open up this f2 square
for Bishop f2 idea
so it's rook f4 huh rook f4 if Bishop
takes rook there's Bishop to e7 Bishop
blocks we take the bishop mate and on
rook f4 pawn takes rook bishop f2 game
over
uh-huh that's the trick yeah that's a
clever one all right that's a nice start
let's try puzzle - ooh King and pawn
ending I don't come across too many of
these very simplified position Oh team
white
okay well oh this one isn't so bad
alright in order to get this fun we have
to approach him in this direction if we
go here we're not threatening to win
this pawn you know I'm not quite sure
what we would be doing if we play here
this is the only move well I'm
considering right now let me just say
this much I'm considering a King move
not a pawn move if we're moving this
pawn then white is really quick to hunt
him down and then come back over to try
and defend the C pawn
so I believe we just play king v3 I'm
not sure what the computer will even
play for black King d5 seems pretty
natural King b3 King to five King a for
I don't know King C for we grab the pawn
and then it's just we start pushing the
F pawn this must be it approaching the
pond from the front yeah I don't see any
any trick here we just scoop up the a
pawn as soon as the King plays here we
could play a four and just start rolling
yeah there's nothing there's nothing
more to this one if King c3 we play f4
if King takes c2 we're just going to be
faster because let's just consider King
C 3 F 4 King takes pawn our King is on
f4 how many moves for us to Queen one
two three four how many moves for black
to Queen one two three four five well
actually a sixth because the King has to
get out of the way of the C pawn so yeah
that's going to do it what's the
alternative for the King to hunt this
guy down we get the C pawn while he's
doing that so yeah that's the trick just
approaching the pone from the front and
let's see what this last one will bring
here okay huh
well if this move isn't crying out to be
played I'm not sure what is Queen takes
f6 King g8 Queen F am 8 mm I don't have
any other candidate moves I'm
considering Queen takes here I know what
I'm doing on King g8 suppose King h6
enter the night he can
a check enough seven don't know that
that would be it though
hm-hmm as tempting as this is it might
it be rook takes f6 I mean that's
throwing it pretty serious punch as well
the threat to move and landed discover
check but let's still revisit this okay
it's the most forceful Queen takes f6
King here mate so Queen takes f6 King h6
what would we have there the pawn is
pinned to the king from that position I
don't know that we could really take
advantage of that that's sure Queen
takes f6 King h6 hmm okay we could go to
f8 but then we're dropping the knight
okay let me maybe rule this for now if
Cooke takes f6 after King here what are
we doing I don't really see it oh hang
on for a moment might there be
some trick with night here landing a
fork mm-hmm I don't think so oh wait a
second I mean is this the solution I
mean we just take the pun and then take
the bishop don't tell me that's how this
group is going to end where we just take
the pawn with check and then recapture
the bishop that would not be cool man
no can't be that I'm expecting more I'm
expecting more from this puzzle right
here could be I mean it still is that
material plus but it's not much actually
yeah it's not very much we would have a
night and they'd have two pawns still in
exchange for the night so yeah it's I
don't think it's going to be Queen takes
pawn King age six and then us taking the
bishop all right what about Queen f6 qh6
Knight f7 rook takes they just take I
mean this is something to maybe consider
after Queen takes f6 King h6 to move the
knight so that we have this h4 square
available
hmm that's tricky not sure what to do
here after King to h6 hmm for a moment I
was thinking after Queen takes f6 King
h6 97 threatens Queen g5 but they could
just take our night and I'll saw a bear
in mind they're still on our ruck if
we're not continually throwing strong
punches if we're not very directive with
our moves mm-hmm I'm pretty much locked
into this takes on f6 with the Queen I'm
just still trying to work out what to do
after king h6 Queen f6 King h6 this
check does not amount to anything King
takes tonight we don't have the f4
square with our Queen Queen takes pawn
six rook out five what is that even
threatening it'd be a different story if
this variation with our queen on f6 the
King on h6 in the rook on their five if
we had the pawn on h4 we would be
threatening rook h5 we would be
threatening Knight f7 followed by rook
h5 and after King takes rook Queen g5
mate but we don't have that pawn on each
for here but I don't know it's something
to maybe kind of ponder some maybe you
could make it work somehow clearly I'm
still in the brainstorming phase with
this puzzle just gathering information
and then trying to somehow piece it
together for a solution so I am a bit
stumped here would it really be uptakes
mmm I'm really I'm I feel like I'm ready
to give up on this puzzle that's the
just being honest that's the feeling I
have right now can you relate have any
of you wanted to just give up on a
puzzle it wouldn't be the first one that
I've given up on before but yeah I'm
really just scratching my head and with
this one Queen takes f6 it's gotta be
that man it's gotta be that let's see
you any other start oh oh wait a second
about Queen takes here King age six and
then just for a cage for a cage for how
you stopping that is that it okay well
there's some stuff to work out at that
point regarding uh black giving checks
to us but no that must be it then Queen
takes f6 King h6 rook F rook f4 is
threatening me in one how do you stop
that really show me how you stuff in her
gauge for if you didn't start a check
there's King f2 or maybe even King takes
bishop yeah actually it would be King
takes Bishop because Queen f6 King h6
rook f4 if rook e1 king F - there's rook
f1 King takes bishop then they take the
rook on f4 so Queen check Keeney h6 rook
f4 if rook e1 king takes bishop we're
then vulnerable to diagonal checks I
don't see a great diagonal check yeah
now really seeing that if rookie two we
approach the rook and throw a punch at
the rook
Queen c6 King f1 attacking the rook
we're still on that h4 square for me so
I think I have worked out the rook e1
check but let's consider once more one
more move I should say after Queen f6
King h6 rook h4 suppose King here
now we must have a mate
and I see it it would be rook h4 and I'm
King takes rook that I the knight posts
up to e4 with a discovered check
controlling g3 stopping the king from
going here and then our next move is
Queen g5 mate let's do it it's correct
okay f4 no checks on that second move
yep
and that's the solution they don't even
take it any further
you can't stop rook to f4 if I'm to just
bringing up in the analysis here see if
I could size up this window this board
bishop takes here here rook f4 if rook
check we take the bishop I was
mentioning if here there would be rook
f1 they're getting this it's no good so
and rook check we would take the bishop
and then still we're back on with this
oh I was pointing out Queen c6 that
would just drop the Queen but Queen here
we could do this we're attacking the
rook we stalled the mate threat and this
is really the main point after rook F
for if the King goes here to defend
that's mate in one
- and then g5 or King h5 we would give
me that one was a bit of a struggle I
don't know how could I maybe seen this I
reckon move better no I was still
focused on these are checking moves on
move - hmm
I think given I didn't consider this
maybe because I didn't even want to
allow black to insert this check but it
is just a check isn't it or just
scooping up the bishop yeah I just I
think given much consideration to this
rook lift idea threatening mate I was
trying to work out Knight f7 Queen f8 at
stages just considering but okay yeah
not too many candidate moves on the
first move with this one but uh yeah
clearly struggled with this a second
move here look out for okay well as
usual feel free to leave any feedback to
this video feel free to share how you
did with these three in the comment
section below
and as usual I hope you got something
out of it that's all for now take care
bye